the reveals just keep on coming for
Hogwarts Legacy and today we have seven
brand new ones but first we need to
start with something that I think a lot
of us may have misinterpreted it just a
bit and it all starts with this book
here which we now know is officially
called The Field Guide now as we talked
about in our last video they had been
sharing these exclusively on Instagram
in these little Snippets with different
tips and also some secret writing that
we could only see part of it a lot of
the times which led me and a lot of
others to believe that this probably
wasn't being given to us by a teacher
but instead by a student well in this
post right here Hogwarts Legacy brought
all of these together and tweeted them
out in one long video which says it's
time to bend the rules and learn some
tips not included in your Field Guide
here's an unauthorized guide to Student
Life at Hogwarts so this made a few of
us even a little bit more confused so
pink Ravenclaw here on Twitter ask
Chandler wood wait is the unauthorized
guide the field guide or those two
distinct books so then Chandler with a
clarification here the unauthorized
guide is our fun social spin on things a
fun way to show you a variety of things
around Hogwarts via our social channels
the field guide is in game with more
details about it yet to be revealed okay
so we still don't 100 know what all is
going in this field guide I think we can
make a lot of guesses based on other
games in this genre but I think at first
a lot of us thought these tips were
going to be at least somewhere featured
in this guide and then also that
handwriting was going to be something
that we would find along the way kind of
like the Half-Blood Prince book that
Harry finds but it seems like all of
that all of the tips everything we've
been seeing in terms of the writing is
really just the Avalanche social media
team having a bit of fun with this field
guide and sort of giving us an inside
look an unauthorized guide if you will
so now we're left to speculate as to
what all is going to go in this book and
if there will be any more tips we have
seven total tips so far and terrible
those were recently revealed tips that
we did not talk about in the last video
starting with tip number five which this
one gets even more strange because it
starts to write out the tip and it says
secret crossed wands dueling and I think
most of us know this is probably gonna
say dueling Club but then they mark it
out so it's like they have second
thoughts and say no no no we're not
gonna share that one for whatever reason
now we already knew dueling was in the
game and I think now this just about
confirms that there will be some sort of
dueling club that we can participate in
there are two scenes in particular that
I am thinking of when it comes to the
Gameplay trailer the first being this
one right here which clearly shows a
duel in the defense against the dark
arts classroom it's that very same
raised platform that we see Harry use in
the chamber Secrets film or at least it
looks pretty close to it then we have
this scene right here which is pretty
clearly taking place in Hogwarts and it
looks like we are joined with a
companion and are doing battle with
these other students over here in front
of us but those are the specific
instances that I can think of that would
somehow relate to Dueling and so I love
that they have this tip in here because
it just further confirms that there are
going to be extra things to do outside
of just the regular story of the game so
I'm really looking forward to seeing
what all they're able to do around
dueling I mean is there going to be like
a high score list that we can keep track
of and maybe even compare with friends
so many questions so many possibilities
but let's move on to the third big
reveal that we got recently and it is
tip number six in the book here zonko's
joke shop and then the little blurb here
below zonkos is your One-Stop shop for
causing Mayhem and Mischief now we
already knew that zonkos was going to be
in the game but we didn't know how much
it was going to play a part and we still
don't fully know that but one of the
things that fans have been asking and
wanting for for quite some time I feel
like I'm saying that a lot lately which
is a really good sign all of these fan
wishes seem to be like they're actually
happening and becoming realized and the
one here is pulling pranks on other
students the video that they shared on
social media also shows this little
scene right here from zonkos and for any
fan of the Harry Potter our series you
all know that this started out as some
sort of just fun little thing that was
almost like a side deal with Fred and
George here but it wasn't just a
one-time thing the whole pranks thing
actually became even more important
throughout the books and I would argue
really kind of culminated in order of
the Phoenix when the twins use some of
the pranks that they have created to
great effect to pester one Dolores Jane
Umbridge while she is currently the
headmistress at Hogwarts now our next
reveal comes with that extra written
text on the page here it says cauldron
cakes batter is moist good to trade with
fizzing wisby's very sweet pepper imps
strong peppermint lets you breathe fire
if you forgot about fizzing wispies and
what exactly they are Ron in Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
describes them as massive sherbet balls
that make you levitate a few inches off
the ground it's also rumored that they
are made with dried Billy wig stings and
I just ask myself you guys how many
systems is this game going to have I
mean the more we learn about I just
can't wait to see how all this fits
together I mean trading these things
with students this is something that we
have seen in Harry Potter games before
so it's not like it's a completely
original idea but when you just layer
that on top of everything else that
we've already learned about Hogwarts
Legacy and how big it seems like they
are going with this game it's gonna be
awesome when we finally get to see how
all of these systems fit together and
have Hogwarts Legacy in our hands now
the next reveal tip number seven sneak
off in the Forbidden Forest and live to
tell the tale yet another fan request
you guys they already confirmed we're
gonna be able to sneak around in the
restricted section of the library now
additional confirmation that we get to
sneak around the Forbidden Forest and
hopefully Live to Tell the tale look you
knew we were gonna go here at some point
for Missions but the fact that they are
just telling us straight up sneak off in
the Forbidden Forest is incredible it's
awesome I mean I'm running out of
adjectives to use here because I got
gotta say yes I still need to see
gameplay we still need to see how all
this fits together I I feel like I need
to keep reminding people of that because
until we do until we know how everything
fits together it's really hard to make a
determination on how good the game's
going to be but in terms of all the
extras in terms of the way that their
social media and marketing team is
handling things right now they're
knocking it out of the park I mean
everything we are seeing is amazing and
so with that let's move on to our sixth
reveal which again is the little extra
handwriting and this one says mooncalf
interactions brush once a day feed Moon
calf a day with fresh that's kind of all
we can see there and then don't forget
play time and so when I read this I
immediately thought of the menageries of
everything we saw during that scene with
the room of requirement we see the nasal
there and we see just something that
blew my mind the first time we saw it
the fact that we're gonna actually be
able to customize all of this inside the
room of requirement I mean something
that I think fans asked for in kind of
like a dream wish list of what they
wanted to see and we still know very
little about this and how deep the
rabbit hole goes here because I mean
once you open up something like that
it's almost like newt's case where it's
just the possibilities are endless here
so as soon as I read that about the moon
calves I made it with thought of that
room and I was taking the creatures
there to nurse them back to health we
already know about the poachers we've
talked about that in other videos and so
now this little extra tip here giving us
some ideas on how we'll try and nurse
those Moon calves back to health I mean
it sounds like we're gonna be able to
have a pet mooncalf I don't want to say
confirmed but that's how it sounds here
at the very least we're going to be
caring for a moon calf now before we get
to the final big reveal I want to talk
about two other things the first one
here is with this student in zonko's
joke shop I want to talk about their
robes because it does not appear like
they are wearing the traditional house
robes so we already know there's going
to be a great deal of customization when
it comes to what you're wearing in the
game so what we could have here is just
a student who's chosen to wear generic
robes or I've seen some people
speculating does this mean we're
actually going to go to hogsmead before
we even get sorted before we go to
Hogwarts for the first time so this
would definitely be possible if our
character kind of bypasses the whole
Diagon Alley thing and instead they're
introduced to the Wizarding World
through hogsmead and it certainly seems
like that could be the case based on
some of the videos and some of the
things that we have seen so far honestly
I'm not going to read too much into this
one I just thought I would point it out
now the next one here is something that
we have talked about previously and it's
just an expansion of that we talked
about these flowers to garlic and I
should have mentioned it in the video
and I don't know why I didn't but I
thought it was interesting that they had
capitalized garlic and now that we can
see more of that text we can see that it
reads instead bring flowers to garlic
make sure they're not wilted so I know
before there was some speculation about
vampires possibly and the curse that's
going on with Sebastian's sister but now
the way this reads is that garlic very
well could be a person and right now
among those in the Hogwarts Legacy
fandom it seems like librarian is kind
of the top choice for garlic right now
we'll just have to wait and see but
hearing this phrase you know this bring
flowers to garlic make sure they're not
wilted has me wondering like do we get
into trouble and we're trying to be nice
to her and get her back on our good side
so we're bringing her flowers or is it
more like a potion thing and they're
gonna end up being used in a potion I
don't know why would the librarian be
helping us out with a potion then again
maybe she's not the librarian I don't
know but it seems that that one is
definitely moving in slightly a
different direction than what we were
thinking before and then the final and
most recent reveal that we have is
involving Sebastian sallow a new tweet
from Hogwarts Legacy which reads the
sallow family has quite the mystery now
I mentioned this already we have been
talking a lot about Sebastian lately he
has been a clear clear focus by the
Hogwarts Legacy marketing team and
honestly I'm still pretty curious to see
if we get this much about all the other
companions there's part of me that
actually doesn't want to know a lot of
this you know when it comes to the story
things I'm not gonna complain about us
getting information because we begged
for it for so long so I think this is
good but I'm kind of starting to feel
like it's a little bit too much so let's
read what the little card here says and
I don't think we're to the point where
we need to start spoiler tagging things
but I will say if you're someone who
wants to go completely fresh not knowing
anything about the story of the game
then you may actually not want to know
some of these things that they're
starting to reveal here so this one for
Sebastian reads Sebastian is a charming
and extroverted boy whose Twin Sister
Anne suffers from a mysterious
debilitating curse Sebastian is
convinced that her last hope for a cure
lies in the dark arts and he is
determined to find it so the big reveal
there first we got her name which is
Anne but also they're twins Sebastian
and his sister Anne are twins and I'll
tell you what I really love about this
is this is just further setting up that
very difficult moral dilemma that we are
going to face as Dumbledore once said I
can see us having to make a choice
between what is right and what is easy
which anytime you have a game with
choices you want this type of layered
storytelling so first impression of
Sebastian I think with that in initial
trailer people might think he's somewhat
of a rebel he's in Slytherin here he is
breaking the rules you know your typical
Slytherin sneaking around after hours
he's caught by peeves but now we get to
see a completely different side of this
no he has a twin sister who is suffering
from a terrible curse we don't really
know what that is yet more on that in a
future video most likely but from what
we've been told so far it seems like all
of his dealings all of his interest in
the dark arts is purely out of saving
her which obviously an incredibly noble
cause and so you're already rooting for
Sebastian even before we boot up the
game for the first time now we got to
see quite a bit from this very moment
when we have to make this choice in the
dark arts trailer featuring Sebastian
I've done a full breakdown of that video
and I'm gonna put it on the right side
of your screen now check that one out
next as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon